in this video we come back to the
formula of the determinant of a matrix
what will this be equal to what will be
the formula if we have the first row as
the reference the first element a11 will
be multiplied with something
now this something is very important for
the sign here we multiplied with minus 1
raised to the row number plus the column
number as a11 lies in the first row and
the first column we raise minus 1 to 1
plus 1 and to find out what this is
multiplied with we exclude the row and
the column of a11 and write the
determinant of what remains determinant
of this will equal a to 2 times a 3 3
minus a 2 3 times a 3 2 this will be the
first part of the formula two more
elements remain in the first row a 1 2
and a 1 3 what will a 1/2 be multiplied
with minus 1 raised to 1 plus 2
multiplied by the determinant of these
four elements a 2 1 times a 3 3 minus a
2 3 times a 3 1 and what will a 1/3 be
multiplied with pause the video and
write the correct product here this is
what we will have minus 1 raised to 1
plus 3 times this determinant we knew
this formula we just saw it in a bit
more detailed fashion now there are a
couple of terminologies we need to be
familiar with for the element a1 1 this
part here is called the minor yes this
is a minor of a 1 1 and this entire part
is called the cofactor of a 1 1 yes
this is the minor of a 1 1 and this is
the cofactor of a 1 1 similarly this is
the minor of a 1 2 and this is the
cofactor of a 1 2 4 a 1 3 this is the
minor and this is the
factor a good way to remember this is by
knowing that minor means small the
smaller part is minor and the bigger
part is the cofactor every element in
the matrix has a minor and a cofactor so
let's zoom out and find the minor and
cofactor of a three to the minor is the
determinant of what's left after
excluding the row and column of that
element for a three two we eliminate the
third row and the second column the
determinant of these four elements will
equal a 1 1 times a 2 3 minus a 1 3
times a 2 1 this is the minor of a 3 2
for the cofactor we just multiply this
with minus 1 raised to 3 plus 2 this
will be the cofactor of a 3 2 minus 1
raised to 3 plus 2 times this so can we
derive a relation between the cofactor
and minor of an element in a matrix yes
what will be the cofactor of a IJ where
I is the row number and J is column
number remember this multiplied by the
minor gives us the cofactor so cofactor
of a IJ will equal minus 1 raised to I
plus J times the minor of a IJ this is
the relation between the minor and
cofactor of an element the minor is the
smaller determinant part and multiplying
it with this gives us the cofactor we
will look at an example in the next part
of the lesson